a reject nation how you doing last video
for the month of April here we were
gonna watch something that I've heard is
kind of funny actually and I thought it
was just some trailer tease for
tomorrow's trailer for a man and the
wasp which we will be covering its where
were ant-man in the wasp wasp it's only
a forty second video before we do that I
want to say thank you once again
everyone who's joined our patreon for
the month of April full-length TV show
reactions weekly Q&A s and patron the
day shout out for Cameron French Cameron
French a long time ago requested that we
do a reaction to Eddie Murphy's drinking
father's which we did and I've tried
messaging him many times he never gets
back to me so apparently the only reason
he joined our patreon was just so we
could honor that one request well thanks
for being here anywhere Cameron I don't
know why I don't like talking to us I
want to get to know the ins and outs of
who you are now I can only theorize that
you are French French I looked up with
the name French means and there's no
meaning but hey I mean at least we can
associate you with the mustard Empire
and you know as a condiment lover myself
I mean mustards among my very favorites
for that I am grateful and I remember
that camera means crooked nose there you
go have more to work off of let's watch
this 40 second video I thought a man
wasn't infinite he's in every frame you
just can't see oh
joke that's a good
where were ant-man and the wasps buzzing
where was to question
to be a movie just sign may be either on
their way but they went subatomic maybe
they were they're pretty tiny and there
are definitely semantics of a comma so
either spider-man I was really looking
forward to meeting DeVos yeah hey they
made the same joke that everybody else
made yeah as much as I loved infinity
war much as I'm already getting kind of
tired of talking about it
house we go in the new last Jedi for me
except everyone's pretty much on the
same page and man in the wasps I'm
excited to see this movie I know it
takes place before the events of
infinity war but after that the weight
and this is why I'm excited for Deadpool
too as well after the weight the
heaviness of infinity war it's very nice
to lighten things matter up again and go
back to one the franchise's we know in
jizan comedy yeah even this like teaser
trailer for I do I thought was really
cool I like how they all came back not
as their characters but as the actors
the weird thing I couldn't stop thinking
about during this though is that they
address where ant-man is during Infinity
Ward they say like he took a deal and
he's on house arrest I couldn't stop
thinking about that throughout this
whole thing but still I mean I'm
interested to see what they've been up
to while the Avengers I mean I'm sure
that this movie is gonna end in a way
that links to the upcoming Avengers 4
that's what we can say I'm sure some of
this will be reported in other words
reaction right now I'm really excited
for the trailer I mean knowing Disney
Marvel they will drop their trailer 6
a.m. our time and awesome when we do
these reactions I like to be well-rested
gonna know we're gonna do this at
exactly 6 a.m. because it's a good kind
of anxiety of like I gotta wake up at
5:00 all nighter and I don't like
pulling all-nighters anymore eyes Hey I
can't wait for this movie and the
upcoming solo films are getting me even
more excited now because I'm excited to
see how they link to the next adventures
yeah get ready for our reaction tomorrow
hope you guys tune in for that you guys
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell and thanks again
once more to everyone at patreon
especially that crooked nose guy huh
mustard